this is an example of a business that is
um what I call one chart businesses
I'm full of catchy today one chart
businesses so what's a one-chart
business there are times you can look at
one chart and one chart alone can be
your business plan
[Music]
all right we're live what's going on I
haven't seen you in a week I know what's
going on forever
um nice jacket uh by the way that's
fresh wearing white is appreciated
Choice the summer move it's a summer
move you're going to Reuben's party or
what
uh no I I don't think I'm I'm not on
that was it last year that you were in
the Hamptons when Rick Rubin was having
his party and you were like what's this
and you didn't wasn't there some story
like you hung out with all the limo
drivers the Uber drivers yeah the
parking lot instead of basically the the
beach that I went to was Five Doors Down
from his house it's a public beach and
there's a parking lot there and me and
my family were just there hanging out we
drove by we saw like you know Henny
Henry kravis the founder of KKR you know
like 50 billion dollar guy like pull up
at his two billion dollar or two million
dollar Bugatti we park in the parking
lot and I see all these huge escalates
all black Escalades and I see like these
it's mostly like these you could tell
their drivers they're in suits they're
playing soccer and eating sandwiches and
drinking soda and I walk over I'm like
what the hell is this and they're like
oh it's this guy named Michael Rubin who
throws his party I go well who are you
driving and they actually tell me who
they're driving and I'm like I'm seeing
how as I am I I go like all right like
what's the what's the stick on them like
are they a good Tipper what's their deal
are they like spilled the beans on like
what it's like he's like oh this
person's actually broke you know like he
always haggles with us over 500 or yeah
so I hung out the parking lot in Michael
rubin's party
most uh uh relatable Blue Collar thing
to do is just to go and be like hey pass
the sunflower seeds and just start
kicking it with these guys in the
parking lot I saw it it was like a movie
a little bit it was like they were just
like playing soccer and drinking Coke
yeah by the way the way you described
that was definitely like straight out of
like a favela and Brazil you're like
yeah they were just uh drinking
Coca-Cola and eating sandwiches while
playing soccer in the park in the gravel
that's really what they were doing I
mean it was it was it was like but it
was fun and you know it was all like
these Long Island guys like hey what are
you doing you know like that type of
thing I saw a video of that party
and
I think the reaction when they post that
video for most people is like oh my God
like so cool I you know I hope one day I
can attend this the white party at
Michael rubin's house I gotta say I saw
that thing and I was like this would be
my worst nightmare it'd be very
uncomfortable right having to look cool
uh just that alone is already I have a
halfway to Hell having to look cool
dressed up first
Sean's wearing a Mickey Mouse t-shirt
right now just fly
uh by the way I bought this recently
this is new this isn't like some old
thing in the closet this was I bought
this during my trip just now
um
so having to look cool and then going to
a place with a bunch of people who are
super famous and then having to like
be in tell a story be in conversations
and like trying to get into
conversations and then be in those
conversations
I just want to go home I don't even I
just I already want to go home and I
wasn't even invited so Michael Rubin you
could lose my invite is what I'm trying
to say yeah it's like you'd rather play
their their characters in Madden than
actually hang out with yeah I would just
start cleaning it I'd be like I'm just
gonna make myself useful here because
the the rest socializing is not gonna
work I'm just gonna I'm gonna Marie
condo this right now and like
start taking out trash and like I'll
just join the serving the crew like
serving appetizers because I'd be like I
know I will have more fun doing anything
besides this where do you want to go
from here I was looking at a company
called after after.com ever heard of
this after.com
a very good uh domain so an amazing
domain so after.com is cremation as a
service basically and you could pre-plan
it or you can do it after somebody
passes away the reason I actually want
to talk about this it's an interesting
business on its own this is an example
of a business that is
um what I call one chart businesses
I'm full of catchy today one chart
businesses so what's a one-chart
business there are times you can look at
one chart and one chart alone can be
your business plan so for example have
you seen the rise in the popularity of
cremation no popping off nowadays
cremation is like uh
yeah it's in right now so I saw this
chart I thought did not everyone get uh
so basically cremation
um in the United States in like the last
I don't know 20 years or something like
that has gone from like 10 of the
population chooses cremation to over 50
I think it's actually it's almost 60 or
70 now which is like kind of insane I
had no idea this was true
um
uh so burial rates uh are going down and
cremation rates are going way up
um
and you just see that one chart alone
you're like okay in 20 years this the
the thing has shifted where it went from
the super minority to the majority all
right that alone tells me there's room
for building interesting business in
this space it's a one-chart business and
there's actually been several of these
that I've like encountered over the
years like one chart uh one chart can
tell you tell you a full story
um and so this is this is one of them
and uh these guys have built a really
good business on top of this I don't
want to go into too much detail about
their actual thing but I just thought
that was crazy and this is like where
like what you guys had with Trends was
like kind of like a cool business
because you guys would identify trends
like this you would say okay yeah and
the 19 in the 1960s cremation was three
percent and then in 1990s it grew to 17
and right now in 2020 it's over 50
um if that's true then what what are all
the second order consequences of that
who are the providers for this who does
the B2B e-commerce of this who has the
highest SEO ranking for this and that
website's actually being way more
popular than than they realize because
um this is growing over time and so you
take that one chart and you can actually
run a whole business plan off wow so do
they uh I'm a yes you're right and B I'm
looking at after.com
they I don't think they've raised money
they're they're they're Mormons they're
based out of provost uh Provo Utah
um uh this is this is wild how did you
find this uh they reached out because I
was I told people I was buying minority
stakes and businesses and investing in
businesses and I think these guys are
raising money or wanted to I think
they're raising money not try to sell uh
they're I think they're trying to go big
fundraise so
um they reached out this definitely
could be big it's twenty five hundred
dollars
their Tam is everyone right on Earth
we're all getting there eventually dude
but they don't own like uh an oven do
they like they just like it's the
logistics so basically what they do is
they get the lead they then book the
kind of like the they either take the
prepayment if you're gonna do it ahead
of time or um afterwards they they say
okay we will be your provider they can
do like kind of like the full Logistics
so basically you know it's like the
Domino's Pizza Tracker right pick up
drop off delivery like did they do the
whole thing
um you know and you can see kind of Step
by Step where you're at in the process
this is wild uh so to your first point
um our good buddy Jack Smith you know he
started fungal sold it for 750 million
dollars it was making a million dollars
a day in Revenue he told me I was like
Jack why'd you start fungal he's like
well I just saw that uh mobile like like
games on your phone were gonna be really
popular I just saw like a chart I think
he said from Forester research report
he's like I just saw this chart that
says like oh mobile games are like
taking over the world and he was like
what can we make on top of that uh like
and that's why he came up with fungal
which was ads in a game and so he built
an ad Network and it was the same thing
where he's like oh that's a thing let's
just get on that title wave and like
just like no matter which surfboard we
pick Let's just pick a board and
hopefully it will catch and uh and that
was like the same famously Jeff Bezos
says this is how he decided to quit his
job in uh I think he worked at some
private Equity Firm uh that's famous and
he quit his high paying job and was like
I'm gonna go start
I'm gonna go start a uh internet company
why internet company he goes I read a
stat doing my research for at the firm
that the internet is growing uh two
thousand three hundred percent per year
and that blew my mind and if that's true
then I'm gonna go build an internet
company that line is a beautiful line so
we actually use that quote on the front
page of Trends where he goes I started
he goes uh he goes I saw a report that
said the internet was going by twenty
three hundred percent per year nothing
grows that fast unless it's in a Petri
dish uh and he's like that's what I knew
I had to start something and so I wrote
a list of ideas of things that we could
possibly sell on the internet and we
just so happened to choose books yeah
exactly they chose books because he was
like oh I what is the advantage of the
internet you could have infinite
selection because there's there's no
shelf space limit right there's no
physical shelf so he's like what has a
wide selection okay what also won't go
bad can't be perishable it has to be
durable
um and then what all what is easy to
ship and so he's like you know those
three and he's like there's market
demand for it cool books books will be
the place where we start
um by the way I just found uh Steph
Smith so former you know writer of
Trends had a great
um tweet about this actually so I just
pulled this up while you were talking
while I was looking for the quote and
she said uh famously Jeff Bezos had this
stat that made him quit his job what are
the generation defining stats of today
here's number one here's what she had
the cost of mapping a genome has fallen
by a hundred thousand percent over the
last 15 years so it went from like 100
million dollars to less than a thousand
dollars um so mapping genomes if that's
true if the cost is dropping like Like a
Rock what what could be done off that
the second
um College tuition has outpaced how much
people earn by 10x here's this one chart
that uh that shows you know people's
earnings over time and the cost of
college over time it's like College
college going way up that's a one chart
business right there
cyber insurance loss ratios have
increased for years despite exponential
growing rates your loss ratio is
basically how many claims you have so
cyber security is becoming an
exponential issue the percentage of men
under 30 not having sex has tripled in
the last decade so before
um men not having sex was like you know
15 now it's 30 of men are not having sex
under the age of 30. before the age of
under the age of 30. so you just made it
nice um yeah
um
a couple other ones you had in here it
used to be that eight hours of sleep was
a norm on average now people get 6.8
um so the Sleep industry and the like
effects of of not sleeping are gonna go
gonna go up
um the electronic system in a car was
five percent of car costs now it's 50 of
car costs
um it's not just self-driving cars
there's cars are basically rolling
computers dude those are brilliant you
you like I've I've definitely have
started stuff because I've seen things
like that I remember sitting with one of
the founders of com this guy Alex II and
we were at lunch
and he just burst out laughing out of
nowhere and we were like what he goes I
just realized that
there must be like
10 million people a day dying on
Facebook you know what I guess like
Facebook must have so much churn just
due to death he's like they probably
have millions of users churned because
they died every day
that's insane and he just starts he
starts laughing and you're like hey Alex
like you freaking autistic weirdo like
he's just laughing so maybe normal he
was like can you imagine millions of
people turning because they died every
day from your product he's like he's
like what do they do with those profiles
how does that work he's like what
there's a team of people just like the
morgue at Facebook just cleaning up
these dead profiles unless you sign up
for afternoon more people died during
lunch today than use our product you
know like more people on Facebook died
than have ever used our product he was
just laughing on control yeah you're
like yeah that's hilarious Alex that's
that's so funny
so this is my first time recording back
in Austin so basically most Summers
between like May and October I go to New
York because I have family there and we
like to stay there this time we only did
it for like six weeks and I'm back and
every time I come back I get this
immense amount of stress because
typically when I go I'll go for three
months and I only bring a carry-on so I
basically bring
um a pair of Crocs a pair of workout
shoes and one nice dress shoes and then
I bring like two workout shorts two
workout shirts and I just clean them
regularly Crocs workout shorts a box of
Captain Crunch and a switchblade yeah
that's called Summer ready
with the yo-yo like those little little
pager things on my belt
yeah I got my Omega my cross
it's a bubble gum and I'm good
okay so you so why do you say you're
stressed out what do you mean you're
stressed stressed about what because all
right so I I bring nothing basically I
bring very little stuff and I rent a
furnished place and then I in my book
bag I bring two lights for the podcast
an extra cell phone that I hang up and
that's my camera and this microphone and
I come back to my house and I realize
I've got a closet full of stuff I've got
two cars that I gotta go like all right
I gotta make sure that like the battery
didn't die I have a motorcycle I got to
make sure the battery didn't die the
tires are full I've got this cold plunge
where I got to go like make sure I
filled it with water and I gotta clean
it I just have like like there's
just stuff there's stuff to like
maintain and I saw a picture of our
friend sahil and he had his baby uh
Roman a beautiful baby but in the back
he had literally
three barrels they were barrels they
were not buckets they were barrels of
toys and I see all this stuff that I
have now and I'm stressed out about this
stuff I've got to go Ranch an hour and a
half away I gotta go check in on I have
all this stuff and I'm freaking out
about having kids about all this other
stuff I'm gonna get Sarah's making like
a a baby shower registry and I see all
this stuff and it's so much stuff it's
freaking me out man I don't want any of
it and I'm wondering I don't think you
freak out over this because I think you
you probably have a lot of stuff I got
all but I for one and freaking about it
have you you don't live lightly at all
bro
living heavy might be the title of my
autobiography
living lightly
um yeah I indulge uh our kids have tons
of crap that's what kids do they they
bring a bunch of crap into your house I
got a dog dog's not some crap I got some
crap there's just stuff everywhere I
literally have a ball pit and a tent and
a fort and uh like you know I have so
much stuff in every single room if you
saw this room I'm in right now you would
want to like pass out but I gotta say
I'm not I'm no therapist but I kind of
feel like what you're having is actually
um
like fatherhood fear and you're just
redirecting it misguiding it and
pretending that you're worried about the
stuff I think this is some underlying
life's about to change I'm about to
become a parent about to lose my freedom
and I think it's expressing itself in
some weird ways like when you get hives
because you're worried about your math
test well I get a little nervous and you
might be right but also I get a little
bit nervous just about all the stuff I
have in general so I was talking to my
buddy Dennis and he's got he's a single
guy he's got three cars and he's like I
have all these cars and like I gotta go
like run them to make sure because I
haven't driven this thing in a month I
gotta go like drive it around I'm like
dude it's like we all wanted this
and then we all got it and now we
realize we just go take care of it and
like if I see someone with a Ferrari I'm
like man if you get a flat tire that's
like a ten thousand dollar like repair
to like get that to you where you need
to go where you got to repair it and you
got to fix it and everything right it
just takes so much mental space and so
what are you gonna do you're gonna give
it all away you're just gonna cry about
it what's the situation now the
situation is you have to be a conscious
consumer I think which is like my
woo-woo phrase of the week but basically
I have to be really really careful and
so I'm going to the baby registry and
I'm like if it doesn't like if it's not
a book we shouldn't ask for it and we
should actually like basically say to
people don't buy us anything but like
I'm just I'm trying to say or if you
want something and they sell at Target
you have to walk there and get it other
because I don't want all these boxes
around the house we gotta like it's
isn't it crazy that we buy stuff it
comes from Amazon then we have to pay
1-800 got junk to come and we give them
300 to go throw away all the stuff you
know what I mean like the boxes it's
it's weird so I'm just gonna buy less
stuff that's basically what I'm gonna do
I think is that not the answer I think
you're on the right side of History
um although I think with kids is a
different game like for example one of
the reasons I got a lot of stuff is
saying you're on the right side of
history is such like a woo-woo way of
saying I agree like it's like the right
side of history is what like uh
political people use you're in the right
side of History you know why it works
because you're talking about the most
minor personal pet peeve so I gotta
elevate it by saying you're on the right
side of History making it feel a little
more Grand okay that's a little trick
you don't I think it's weird that you
don't experience this I think a lot of
people are experiencing this right now
and they're and like when you go to some
people's homes they they have a basement
full of stuff and I'm like dude a
cluttered a cluttered room is a
cluttered brain in my mind I threw away
I hired a guy to come over cleared my
calendar I hired a guy to come over and
he just took so much crap out of our
house uh like we just removed everything
out of the garage he took a whole dining
table chairs a rug that I didn't like
just took loads of stuff away and it
felt like you know the satisfaction when
you like pop a zit or something like
that it felt like that yeah I popped my
house this is it it does feel great when
you get rid of stuff and you lighten the
load but
what I would say is one of the reasons I
had a lot of stuff I have a lot of stuff
as a as a parent is because
you end I don't know not everybody does
this to better parents than us but we
bribe our kids a ton and it turns out
that like the thing you want more than
like a neat and tidy home and foot light
footprint is like
13 minutes of relaxation and you know
how you get 13 minutes of relaxation you
stop at freaking Dollar General or
whatever and you buy some crap that your
kid's gonna be excited about playing for
like
30 minutes and like that's all you need
and you if you have that all right it's
worth it we'll get rid of that later and
so having stuff that your kids can play
with
is how you get to be on the internet and
if you don't want to be on the internet
cool keep your minimal house and you can
go and entertain your kids with your
bare hands but if you don't want to do
that you better buy the ball pit and the
slide and the Nugget and like all these
little things so that they have stuff in
the Target you you've got the target
grocery cart exactly check out because
then I can say oh let's play grocery
store you go shopping and buy everything
and I'll be sitting over here on my
laptop and then they do it and another
nine minutes passes and I'm just nine
minutes closer to freedom to the day
that they're old enough to go to school
and so you know this is uh it's a really
it's a tool for survival is what I'm
trying to say yeah and the last thing on
this is the reason I love going to New
York is when I go is because
I say like San Francisco and New York
where I lived in San Francisco for 10
years you're you're outside of San
Francisco now New York as well it's a
land of ones and tens meaning everything
about that place is either a one out of
ten or it's a 10 out of 10. the beauty
the energy the excitement 10 out of 10.
the crime like seeing the homeless
people do stuff like like like feeling
like it's a third world country
sometimes that's a one out of ten Austin
is a land of six and sevens everything's
mostly pretty good mostly all the time
it's never going to blow you away with
inspiration but it's always gonna be
like oh this is nice I feel nice whereas
you know you walk around the city of New
York and like some of the time you're
like this makes me feel alive you know
like this is like I just like inject the
my veins and then the other times
you're there you're like I need space I
need quiet like I'm freaking out you
know what I'm saying and so what I'm
trying to figure out is what's a good
life is it surrounding yourself with
ones and tens or is it surrounding
yourself is seven all the time and
that's something that I that we're
debating at the moment I mean this is
that's a big life question what do you
think the answer is I don't know yet I
don't have to make my decision yet but I
was wondering if you've ever thought
about that uh I've never thought about
it as well as you just put it what I
would say is that anytime uh I learned
this thing a long time ago which is one
choice is no choice right because if you
have if you only have one choice that
means you really actually have no choice
yeah just inertia two bad choices just
tells you you need a third choice and so
I think what you're actually saying is
you need a third choice
um like
you know the thing that worked for me
was live in California but live in The
Burbs so you don't have the crime and
stuff like that you do lose a little bit
on the energy in the like kind of
ambition around you but you can kind of
hack around that a little bit
um so you get kind of the weather the
beauty the the sort of the the
California Sunshine all that good stuff
um without the the downtown San
Francisco crime and
um you know recklessness lawlessness I
think what I'm gonna do and we could
wrap up here I think what I'm going to
do is I'm gonna we're gonna rent a place
for one year in Westport Connecticut
never in a million years did I ever
thought I'd say I'd live in Connecticut
but I met this woman who I'm going to
talk about dafina Smith and she goes I
like I met her through Hampton and she
was like I know what you're going
through I went to the same thing we
found this place called Westport
Connecticut 60 minutes outside of New
York City it sounds crazy but come and
visit me I went out there and I was like
this is nice
so I might do Westport Connecticut but I
can't believe I might be a Connecticut
person but I think that's what we might
do speaking of what you want me to talk
about her yeah tell me the story uh I
met this woman at a Hampton dinner I sat
next to her uh basically her name is
dafina Smith and her her store or
company is called covet in Maine so you
can check it out it's a covet like you
want something so c-o-v-e-t and then
main like hair m-a-n-e are you on the
website yeah there's just uh
like you know I don't want to go Rick
rubin's party but this party that I'm
looking at right here looks amazing this
is just like beautiful women running
through the like just holding hands and
running through the sand which is just
hilarious
dude so check this out so she started
out in real estate just doing normal
stuff but her parents own a beauty
supply uh like store like a brick like a
small store and so she starts helping
them out and so she starts saying like
oh let's create a website and we'll sell
hair extensions online
um so you I don't know if your wife uses
hair extensions my wife does sometimes
hair extensions basically it costs
sometimes two or three thousand dollars
for really fancy ones sometimes cheaper
500 to a thousand dollars and they
basically like weave this they're
basically like so extra hair into your
hair and it makes it look really nice
for a woman and she starts selling this
online she's like this doesn't really
work that well the way the way that I
thought it was going to work so instead
what she does is she invests around 100
to 150 000 into starting this business
and what she does is she starts
hollering at different
um
beauty stores and she creates like an
invite system where she's like look we
don't have that much inventory and we
want to like onboard people effectively
uh so you just apply and then if we can
like make this happen we'll start
setting you out our product and our
products is really high quality and then
also we can start sending you some
customers because we're going to do
really good with the marketing we're
going to send people who want our
particular type of hair and hopefully
when you go and get hair you'll tell
your friends oh I got this brand of hair
you can go to their website and see who
deals their stuff well anyway
she only has six employees in her first
year of business they did four million
dollars in revenue and they're in year
four or five and they're doing tens of
millions in Revenue by year two she was
already in the tens of millions uh year
four she's doing many tens of millions
they have like two or three agents
agencies who work for her but only about
six full-time people and if you go to
their website they're killing it and I
was like how what are you doing so well
she's like man we host these like
meetups where it'll be like tons of uh
women who own these beauty supply
companies so or like you know like
literally a brick and mortar like beauty
store and we do like these parties where
we like teach them a little bit about
how they run their business we'll have
speakers who like have best practices
and then also like if they happen to
want to apply to sell our product we'll
do that and that's like basically how
they're getting most of their customers
and it's a super fascinating company
because a it's just a simple
ish website I mean it's nothing like
crazy fascinating her the uh the hair is
of high quality which by the way do you
know how they get hair from this no is
it donations it's real hair it's usually
no it's from it's from India so like
there's I guess in certain parts of
India it's like holy or something to
shave your head or they go to China
where you can pay people and they'll cut
their hair and you buy their hair from
them and so it's real hair and so it's
like a process to get like a high
quality hair extension but she built
this company on on on this on this idea
of like going after these hair slots and
it's super fascinating because a this is
an industry that I knew nothing about
and B I actually think things like this
could be pretty huge because it cost two
or three thousand dollars to get this
done in some cases so I forgot I
actually went down this Rabbit Hole a
long time ago because a guy I did dinner
with Once uh you know when I used to
host these Mastermind dinners
um worked at this company called Maven
did you ever hear about this company
yeah they they raised too much money I
think they raised like 30 million
dollars from Andreessen Horowitz and
Serena Williams and Jimmy iveen like oh
you know every cool person you can
imagine
and um so they raised all this money and
this guy Taylor came to dinner and he
was I think like the CEO or something
like that they're based in Oakland
and he was telling us about this he was
like uh is you know basically one guy
explaining to like five other guys
who've never like done hair extensions
about how crazy this business is and
he's like yeah like you have these
stylists the stylists are basically like
you know these kind of like independent
contractors people follow them from like
Salon to Salon like wherever they're
working they're trying to book them and
then the stylist has to go and procure
the actual hair and so they go to like
these warehouses or these wholesalers to
go buy the actual hair and then they get
the hair from India and I remember going
on a YouTube rabbit hole of like
how they get the hair from villages in
like India or China or places like this
because that's where the bulk of the
hair gets imported from and how they get
paid you know whatever dollars for for
their hair and it's like kind of a
controversial thing about like you know
is this
like is it exploitive there's like
rumors of like people being forced to do
it which is not great
um and so there's all kinds of stuff in
the supply chain about ethically
sourcing the hair and there's some great
videos on YouTube about this if you're
ever curious I you know I recommend this
is like a fun fun Rabbit Hole to go down
um I don't know what happened with Maven
because I think they raised a lot of
money
and I haven't heard about them in a long
time and
um it looks like they raised 40 million
more to go into Walmart I mean it looks
like there's 76 million in total they've
raised 76 million dollars a lot I don't
know why and I know no offense to uh to
Taylor uh no no offense to Taylor I hope
they hope they succeed but there's
something about companies with this
pattern of like
um
cool idea usually underrepresented
founder going after space that that you
know white Tech startups ignore then
like raises Mega round from celebrity
investors
and then you kind of don't hear about
the fruit like maybe they raised too
much money like too much money can break
companies this happened with uh like
that Tristan Walker's company like
Walker and yeah whatever the Walker
Brands they made like a razor for black
men to shave their head I think uh yeah
or their beard or whatever and I think
that was a great idea
um I was a great like model but when you
raise that much money it puts so much
growth pressure on the business it can
sometimes break it and so I hope that
this didn't break it but um
I've just seen this happen several times
now start to start to notice a little
bit of a pattern yeah it says in a press
release that they have they've done it
says they did 120 million in Revenue but
they phrase it in a way where I think
that means the company's life span
they've done 120 million in Revenue but
yeah it's stupid I think your cap table
is like one of the very few things in
business that is an irreversible
decision it's very challenging to make
up for that mistake and so this is why
this woman uh dafina like when I met her
I was like I started talking to her I'm
like are you on social media she's like
a little bit but I haven't decided if I
actually want to go all in on it and I
was like
you're if you Google this lady you'll
see our names dafina Smith I'm like you
you could be you know you could be like
a huge deal if you wanted to like you
what what do the kids say you got the
Riz she's got the wrist she's like this
like very charismatic very pretty tall
like composed like when I see her talk
I'm like oh man you're like a proper CEO
like you got the if Factor uh and
she's like she's like I don't know if I
actually want to be famous or I don't
know if I actually want to go hard that
way or I'm like well whenever you want
to I think you'll kill it and so I saw
when she started telling me her story I
had no idea that this stuff could be
this big and she told me some of the
numbers behind it and I was like
flabbergasted at this type of business
uh yeah that's crazy
um so so her model is this kind of like
direct to stylus model there's a few
other businesses that are like this have
you heard of style seat yeah I like
style seat uh my wife used it for a
little while what exactly is it though
there was a period of time where like or
this happens a lot in business where
there's a period of time where one idea
like when an idea works it can work
across like a couple of verticals not
all verticals but a couple of verticals
and if you figure it out it makes sense
so there was a time when like uh Mind
Body online was getting uh popular is
basically like this idea of sort of like
directly booking online booking of yoga
classes online booking and Pilates
classes and then the fact that there was
like this rise of the instructor like
the celebrity instructor this happens
with Peloton it happened with yoga it
happened with Pilates there's like
people started there people realize that
you're not coming for the venue you're
coming for the specific instructor and
the same thing is true and by the way
that that Mind Body Company so mindbody
was software for yoga classes originally
I think they went public I think it's
like a wildly yeah it's like a billion
dollar thing
um and with very like old school
software like it wasn't like slick new
fresh blah blah blah
um but people started to realize that
like same thing it was true for stylists
like you don't go to the hair so some
people go to the local you know like me
my selection of where I'm getting my
hair cut is like what is the closest
place to me in that moment that I have
30 minutes right like I'm going there
yeah yeah which Great Clips is available
at the moment who's gonna pick it up
Bowl to put on there dude I just got a
haircut in L.A I went to this fancy La
place because I was this is the nearest
place I went in and I sat down and then
he started cutting my hair he's like oh
what do you want blah blah I was like uh
I don't know can you cut my hair like
the standard dude cut
um I don't even know what it's called
and then he's like uh okay I think
that's what you're talking about he
starts and I go is he fake I go I was
like um I was like oh shoot uh because
he was going so slow he was like cutting
every individual hair with the scissors
to like make it awesome
and I go actually
um different instructions can you give
me the best haircut you can in 15
minutes
and I was like yeah I only want to be
here for like 15 minutes can you just do
your best inside a 15 minute time slot
and he was like I don't know if I should
be offended or like this is exciting it
was just like all right
15 minutes he's like can you put a timer
on I go yeah and I put a timer on and
then this guy like cut the out of
my hair for 15 minutes and I was like
wherever you're at when you're done
let's just call it he's like you can
come back later he's like you can come
back later today man I'll finish and I
was like it's hair it'll be it'll be
it'll be there
he's like he's like I won't charge you I
was like uh you couldn't pay me to come
back you know I'm done I don't
understand
dude I go to these Orthodox guys about
my hair I go to these I go to these
Jewish guys in Brooklyn and I love them
because it's all about efficiency and
then I'll end up just sitting down at
the chair anyway just be like tell me
about it Uzbekistan I want to hear some
stories but like I want a place where
they're just gonna call me bub and
there's gonna be a a handwritten sign
that's hopefully misspelled that says
haircut 28 beard trim eight dollars like
that's what I want like you better have
scotch tape in that drawer of yours like
otherwise I'm out if you take credit
cards I'm out
yeah so
um anyways I don't know how I got out of
that anyway style C made it easy to book
a stylist and I think they got valued at
one point like at a nearly a billion
dollars and Melody the the woman who's
been running it she's been doing this
for like a decade now
um I'm really curious to see how that
one that would plays out because she
also raised a bunch of money and and
kind of was going for it but this this
hair salon barber thing is kind of big
like I don't know if you've seen Squire
that's another billion dollar company in
this space what's Squire Squire is the
same thing for barber shops so it's
basically like Barbershop booking
software
um so you know it's a it's an app that
lets you book you know book your Barber
mobile Barbers were always like you know
pick up the phone they're cutting
someone's hair they pick up the cordless
phone they're like yeah come on in uh
what's your name and they're like can't
even write it down because they're
cutting someone's hair at the same time
so Squire just kind of like streamlined
that process and I think they might do
payments as well
um so like people providing software to
these brick and mortar um like small
businesses
is really it's a really really hard
Niche but when you if you can do it if
you can get the product product Market
fit the scale is really big because
there is a lot of these small frag like
it's a giant fragmented market and
there's so many of them that if you can
actually figure out a product that works
on a sales model that works which is the
two hard things
um these things can be a lot bigger than
they sound because it sounds like oh
software for hair stylist who cares um
well it turns out it's actually there's
a lot of them yeah and I would never
want to work in that industry because I
think it's it does seem impossibly hard
but uh if you're into it it can work
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better let me give
you a blue collar side hustle so uh we
haven't had one of these Blue Collar
side hustles in a while so uh we're
bringing it back would you like you like
took one flight and you were around Blue
Collar people and you got inspired I
left my house and I you know I was
around somebody who listens to the
podcast so uh shout out to brisha she uh
owns this amazing restaurant in L.A
I don't know if you know this so she
listes the Pod and she's like every time
you guys shout out you're like four
female listeners I'm like yeah that's me
like you know I feel so good and then
dude a lot of women are offended by that
I don't say that anymore I still say it
because I say it with with endearment
um you know lead I lead into the joke
um the problem is the joke's not that
funny so you know it it may not be the
right thing to lean into but I'm minute
um so anyways I go to she has this
restaurant in La how did you meet her
she had taken my power writing course
and
um she had volunteered to like I do this
thing where I'm like okay show me your
website and we do like a live teardown
of it and so we had done one of her
website uh because she sells these like
michelada like drink things
um like this kind of like mobile or
sorry this little like uh she has like a
restaurant but she has like this
e-commerce side of her business too so
anyways okay I've done a tear down of it
didn't pay much attention to it after
the fact but Ben
um business partner Ben keeps in touch
with anybody that I meet he's just like
somehow has tabs on everything he's like
yo she's blowing up in La I'm like what
do you mean it's like she's got this
restaurant
um she was blowing up like the
restaurant's getting really popular her
brand is getting really popular she's
got a podcast that's getting kind of
popular
um and he's like yes what's her full
name let's get we'll give her a proper
shout out what's her full name brisha
Lopez okay so uh she and she's got a
cookbook like she's kind of like doing
her thing she's got a lot of a lot of
stuff going on which I think is pretty
fun she got a book called Assad of the
art of Mexican style grilling by bricia
Lopez um I met her and her brother so
anyway so she invites us she's like hey
you're in L.A you're having meetings
anyways come to our restaurant and uh
like you know or whatever we come to her
restaurant she serves us this amazing
meal you know we talk about restaurant
owner owner energy she had it she
literally has restaurant owner energy
like we walked in we're in her place
she's like sit down food just starts
appearing we're not ordering anything
she's literally like making my plate by
hand she's like she's like feeding me
like I'm a baby she's like try this was
it free did you have to pay I wish I
could have paid she's like your money's
no good here and uh wow the restaurant
owner energy was flowing I loved it uh I
literally when we walked out our buddy
was like wow is that what it's like to
own a restaurant and then our other
friend was like this is how every
entrepreneur makes the mistake of owning
a restaurant because they experience the
one percent amazing feeling when you
host people at your restaurant and not
the 99 of actually you know running a
hard restaurant
so she uh
anyways we're hanging out she's like I
love the Pod she's like I love the blue
collar side hustles and I was like oh
yeah I haven't done that in a while she
goes I got one for you okay what is it
she goes The Lice Lady
what are you talking about it's just she
goes she goes dude uh she's like I have
kids that are in school and
um
if you ever if anybody in class gets
lice everybody has to get checked for
lice and not just not just all the kids
like your whole family basically has to
get checked for lice and she's like I'm
thinking of like the pigeon lady in the
park who has pigeons all over the place
is this I got I was thinking like it's a
woman that just has lice all over like
hanging out her shoulders and she feeds
them crap uh go to like one of these I
don't know like lice treatmentla.com
it's a mobile lice testing service so
what she's what she said was she goes
yeah basically somebody inevitably gets
licensed School everybody then has to
get tested before you you can't come
back until everybody gets tested clean
certified clean so then you can either
go and do it like or if you want them to
come to you because it's time consuming
to like go and book an appointment
somewhere you can basically there's a
lice lady you could just text in La you
text her and she's like cool I'll come
out there it's 300 bucks for me to come
out I'll test you and your whole family
plus like I don't know 50 bucks a pop or
something like that 100 for like your
certificates and it's basically like she
makes you know like whatever 500 600
dollars for doing this like test for the
whole family to get them all cleared and
she serves like these like eight
districts in L.A and like that's her
territory and there's like another lady
out on the east side and she serves her
territory and they don't cross paths
otherwise there's a bit of a showdown
and so um she's like yeah this lady's
making tens of thousands of dollars a
month just booked she's booked out with
these lice inspections and lice
treatments I was like wow this is
awesome this is I mean who would have
ever who would have ever thought uh you
know like this is amazing because you
know she comes over she got to check
four or five people in your house and
it's a whole it's a whole deal
dude and a lot of them have like pretty
cute branding this one's called
thelacelifters.com and then there's like
hairhelpers.com
thehairangels.com and they're all just
made on like pretty simple WordPress if
you go to simpler web they get great
they're getting traffic and then uh
they've like just crushed it on the
Google review and the Yelp review and
some of them have like I'm at
licelifters.com they have locations in
Florida Texas Pennsylvania uh New Jersey
it's almost like a like a franchise this
is super fascinating this is really fast
very cool right like it's uh you know
lice Busters here we go you know we'll
come get you
um it's crazy yeah they they this is
like a little model that I think works
locally if it works locally you could do
it in a bunch of locations if you do it
a bunch of locations you could even
franchise it out or go Nationwide if you
if you really got aggressive with it so
I kind of love this this little uh this
little blue collar side hustle and it's
one of these like hidden in plain sight
niches right it doesn't take a genius to
uh to pull this thing off dude if you go
to licebusters usa.com the one you're on
I mean I made that up by the way is
there actually oh yes I just Googled
lifebusters licebusters usa.com they
have a couple dozen locations
uh no this is a really a super
fascinating thing
um yeah this is cool how much does it
cost to have a lice Buster come to your
school I bet you it's like a thousand
dollars for the day or something none of
them yeah exactly none of them do like
clear pricing on their website which is
how you know it's kind of a rip
um but like you know they got you in a
hard spot too right it's like a
locksmith right they come over they're
like well
um uh this is a 1988 it's got to be an
extra five hundred dollars you're like
well
am I really gonna tell you to go home
call another locksmith to price compare
like impossible right like no one no one
has more power on Earth than a locksmith
when they're at your house like it is
over you know
you know that's like a huge scam right
have you ever read about locksmith so I
knew this guy from Israel who ran one of
these things and he was like if you
Google locksmith Nashville he's like
there's like eight of the ten listings
on Google they're all different branding
I own all of them and I basically like I
have like indentured servants so I got
like my friends who come in from Israel
I say you have to work for me for two
years and he basically sends him leads
and the name of the game is you go to
the person's house you tell them it's
200 on the phone you actually charge
them 400 and it's like known for being
one of the most Shady things there is
it's the locksmith industry have you not
like ever heard of it I've never never
been an honest locksmith uh guy comes to
my house he's like ah you know first he
takes it forever
and it's like basically takes so long
that you're like by the time this gets
there you're already worn out it's like
a negotiation without him even being
there and then it's too late to call
somebody else you just want to get into
your damn car or your house and then
they show up and they're like uh this is
gonna be trickier because the
um this is a house yeah of course it's a
house it's like yeah it's got studs so
it's going to be
and I'm like study what are you talking
about bro he's like oh like this oxygen
in the air uh I'm gonna have to charge
it for that and oh it's made out of wood
and literally what happened the last
locksmith guy came and he tried to
charge us 600 and then we were like no
way just out of principle no way you
stand here I'm gonna break this door
down with my shoulder and get it
repaired for double looksie like all
right fine 100 bucks no he stood there
and he watched us break the door down
with our shoulder and then we paid 1200
to get the door repaired
um I gotta tell you it never felt more
satisfied paying the 1200 because that
sheet didn't get my money what did he
say what did you smash the door down
very Alpha of you you were just laughing
well dude imagine the intent imagine the
moment of anticipation when I'm about to
charge and I've only ever seen the
in movies I have no idea how much Force
this is going to take and if this fails
if I get slam into this yeah I hurt my
shoulder and fall down the absolute
worst case scenario now we gotta pay
this guy and I gotta go to Kaiser
instead it's like I must get through
this wall and like you know like moms
can lift cars when their children are in
need like my ego was trapped and I had
to break this door down there was no
other option and of course I came
through in the clutch
um so you know it ended up working out
after two or three solid Banks the key
was I didn't fully commit to the first
one I gave it like a tester just kind of
like uh yeah I'm gonna do it over here
on the side and like when we get to the
edge not a middle middle is the way to
go right like where's the point of
weakness
I can see you standing there like
looking at your figure to see which way
which way the winds blowing like it's
just like calculating I got a piece of
chalk and you like do a little math to
figure out like where the best like
point of entry is yeah just doing things
to stall I just like took my shoes off
like I don't know why like I was just
hold on I'm just thinking like okay what
am I gonna do to get this door down and
you like warm up your heads I don't know
why I needed to perform for this guy
like I could have just told him to leave
and done it in my privacy but I had told
him like that's a rip-off I'm gonna
break this door down all right so let me
tell you
um this is actually a good segue to a
topic I wanted to talk to you about I
didn't know how we would work this in
but it worked out perfect God so there's
this phrase that I love which was
um I'm looking for that I'm looking for
AAA Locksmith AAA Locksmith what's a
triple A laxman so back in the day when
they had the phone Pages people would
the Yellow Pages people would go to like
find a service like locksmith and um
it's like doing four four minute abs
instead of seven minute abs you know you
gotta yeah exactly you could
differentiate on many things you could
say we're a locksmith uh company we're
honest we have we have good pricing we
are a lot nobody knows that they're just
looking at the Yellow Pages they don't
know how to find you find out anything
more about you they're just going to go
based on which locksmith stands out
guess who stands out the most the one at
the top and so
I call it the Triple A locksmith idea
because
people started to game the system
they're like oh instead of calling
themselves Smith's locksmiths like then
they're far down the list they would
call themselves right a locksmith and
then some other guy was like no no we're
double A locksmith so A A Locksmith they
would show up first in the like the list
some other guy comes in he's like no no
I'm AAA Locksmith AAA Locksmith because
they're going to be first on the list
because actually that's all that matters
first on the list is going to get 80 of
the dials and so I love this ex this
story because it showed me like
you want somebody who like I always said
when we were hiring Engineers I want to
hire AAA locksmiths which is somebody
who could do the job on the engineering
side but they have just enough of their
mind just 10 15 of their mind is going
to think about hey how do I get more
customers oh if I just put two A's in
front of my name I'll be at the top of
the list dope I'll do that that that
that immigrant it's like that immigrant
hustle yeah exactly so I want the
engineer that's got just enough of that
that little that moment of micro hustle
where they just figure out oh this
little thing is going to help me you
know help me get a little bit further in
life so I was thinking about these micro
hustles because again I left the house
start to observe things start to notice
how broken some Industries are so I'm
out of dinner
how long were you gone for five days an
eternity okay
um I go to dinner and uh sitting with
some friends and the this happened five
times so we went to dinner every single
night while we were out while I was in
delay every single night the same thing
happened at dinner
we eat at the end waiter comes up and he
says
um can I get you guys a dessert menu
dessert anybody want dessert
dessert and then you know his voice is
going up like a hot air balloon and then
everybody at the table awkwardly looks
around
I you want did you want any did you want
dessert I'm good that's a that's a
that's a rookie waiter move you set the
you just set it down even if you just
set it down the same sort of thing so I
said I said okay what's the micro uh and
and so I was thinking about I was like
what's the micro hustle move here if I'm
a wave so I'm looking for these moments
where you because I meet a lot of people
that are like
love the Pod
um yeah I want to do my own thing
someday but currently I just have this
job and like the gap between the current
job
and running their own successful company
feels large in their mind and here's the
way to shrink that Gap well the real way
to show with The Gap is just do it but
let's say you you're not just doing it
yet yeah teach me about some teach me
about some shrinkage let's go yeah
you're an expert maybe you should
actually explain this yeah yeah yeah
preaching to the choir here so
I'm like how do you start to
think like a business owner think like a
little bit of an of a hustler
when you're in your job find the moments
where you can hustle inside inside your
job and I'm not talking about pitching
your boss an idea I'm talking about just
going rogue and making some happen
learning how to be a triple A locksmith
how to use human psychology to your
advantage so
the last dinner I see this guy and this
guy's a little more clever
one guy he goes he takes instead of
instead of saying dessert menus anybody
want dessert should I bring a dessert
menu
um and instead of just putting down
dessert menu and then hoping for the
best
this guy comes to me at the side of the
table he goes um
he goes he goes all he goes I'll leave
this with you to order dessert for the
table
nice oh that was smooth as a mother
and I was like wow like
I guess I am the head of the table
though the man of the house I do need to
provide for my my friends here you know
I do need to to give them an experience
and he just whispered it to me like this
is our little secret you just tell me
what you tell me what you want we'll
we'll surprise him so I was like that
was a smooth move and I started thinking
what could go even further and so I
started everywhere I was going I started
brainstorming this little micro hustle
moment so then even with this dessert
thing I said who would make it more fun
I said what if what if they actually set
down a thing because most people
when it comes to dessert they it looks
like there's two answers yes or no
but there's actually a third answer do
you know the third answer when it comes
to dessert no what I'll have some if you
want some that's actually where
everybody lands it's like yeah I'll do
one if you're doing one right like this
is how people feel with things and so I
I thought somebody should actually just
set down a little thing in front of
everybody say all right here's a
restaurant at the end of the meal
there's three little buttons I could put
in front of you button number one no
thanks I'm fine button number two hell
yeah butt number three I'll have one if
everyone else wants one and uh on three
we do our reveal we make it fun you do
the reveal if anybody says yes and
anybody says I'll have it if everyone
else is having it say no more would you
guys like the brownies or the truffles
oh okay truffles yeah let's go and you
could get I think you could add on like
forty dollars to every ticket if you
just did it this way dude I love I love
those games like that it's like it's
like In and Out secret menu yes you know
what I mean like I love these games at
restaurants that's my favorite and I
think a lot of life is just played in
your head and if you're just sitting
somewhere the challenge I give everybody
is how do you
play a little game in your head today
where you say all right let me add a
little Showmanship let me add a little
restaurant owner energy to what I'm
doing right now let me add a little
psychology to what I'm doing right now
and if you do that every day you become
a different person like I fully believe
this you literally become a different
person and you have more fun versus just
going through the motions as you were
before so this is my little rant on
finding that little micro hustle uh
being the guy who figures out how to do
the dessert menu in a way that makes
everybody feel good and actually gets
you everyone gets everyone eating
dessert because there's a version of
that for your job whatever your job is
the mini Riz the little mini Riz you did
this at the hustle we talked about when
you did the uh everybody gets a hundred
dollars let's go to Costco and let's see
who gets the best thing right like it
was it was the best yeah that was our
team building activity was we had I
think we had 12 employees we gave
everyone 50 bucks we said you can team
up you can do it on your own but at the
end we're gonna vote we're gonna have
three characters or three Awards which
is most useful gift your favorite gift
and the most tasty gift and you have to
try to win one of those Awards yeah and
I love these stories of people who just
take the ordinary and uh and sort of
like add a little extra to make it
extraordinary all right anyways that's
my rant who who are you at dinner with
or who'd you go to LA with and did you
did anything amazing happen a lot of so
many amazing things happened I wanted to
actually write my notes and send them to
you so that then we could do an episode
just bring breaking the whole thing down
because there was so much uh so much
were you recognized a lot do you get
recognized not at all actually really
LA's got real actual famous people so
um maybe people don't know that you're
like six one I think because a lot of
people I think would be surprised how
tall you are when I go to La I mean I
get stopped a dozen times a day uh I
think I maybe I just stick out more than
you do maybe but it could be uh I'm
shocked by that or you're just super
unapproachable which I could see that as
well yeah I think that's actually more
of it
um I must have just like you know
whatever resting face or something
because uh yeah nobody's really coming
up to me that much it happens actually
here in the Bay Area but when I was in
LA I don't think it happened one time so
that was good uh you know
you're not from L.A no I mean like but
okay humble not a famous fruits
yeah
where uh who'd you go you went with Ben
probably suly anyone else uh no it
should be in band went and then Sully
lives down there so he joined us for
half the trip well I want to hear all
about it so I guess we'll have to wait
uh I got some other quick ones I wanna I
wanna hit you with some some quick
hitters so this is I'm gonna call this
my weird AI tool of the week I don't
know if this is gonna be a recurring
segment but it might be because a lot of
weird AI tools so click this link
there's a company right now in YC that
is called Roundtable roundtable.ai
and I saw this post on hackard news
um it wasn't the most popular post but I
found it and I uh I thought it was
fascinating so this guy goes because
that's what you do that's what you do
you got to find you find the guys
exactly so I was I was I was deep with
the bag and I found something so
um they've posted this lube video that
says hey check this out we are round
table we use AI to simulate surveys and
they go
um they go you know research user
research and market research is really
important but it's expensive takes time
to design and analyze and run this run
the research so here's what we do we use
AI to simulate a survey
and they go yeah basically like llm's
the new tech that's behind like chat GPT
is great at
um simulating what something something
like a human would say
and these years just took it to the
entryway so they go you write a survey
with a bunch of questions you define
your audience like I want people who are
um 45 years old or older right and uh so
you could say
um for example
are you interested in buying an e-bike
um and it would say yes is answered 28
of the time but if you narrow it down
you say let me filter only people who
own a Tesla now yes it's 52 of the time
and you know for example if you say um
where do you where did you learn to code
um
okay you could ask that question people
will say one thing but if you say how
old are you if you say only 45 years old
or older then everybody will say books
if you say younger than 45 70 76 of
people say online
um
and so you know it's kind of crazy that
basically like and you can say what
what's the most important factor for you
choosing an airline to fly and like five
percent of people would say leg room but
if you filter it say people who are six
feet or taller it jumps to 20 of people
saying legroom and so I saw this and I
was like what the hell like does this
defeat the purpose of the survey like
you're literally just gonna make up the
answer and give it to me
but then I guess humans are actually a
lot more predictable than we think that
this thing is trained on like the entire
internet's data set
and I just thought this was remarkable
and I couldn't believe like is this
actually going to be the case that you
can actually just AI could just fake
answer your surveys and tell you do your
user research for you doesn't that sound
absolutely bizarre
so it's not there yet because one person
he goes hey look I had I ran a survey I
said was the moon landing fake option A
yes option b Moon 94 of people voted
Moon
and but that said uh
I actually do think the same results
would actually come if you actually
asked people that exact same question
like most people would be like oh
you know what I mean like oh I think I
know what you're saying you're saying
you meant to put yes there uh so but but
this is like a really thought-provoking
idea yeah and honestly I haven't even
spent enough time like actually figuring
out like is this literally a joke or is
this like the next big thing if that's
kind of interesting anytime you get
something that's like either it's satire
this was actually started exactly or
it's genius it's like you driving around
being like ah it I'll be a taxi did
I ever tell you about the time that I
ran um the Disco by the way that's not
how Uber started just in case you didn't
know
one man just deciding I'll be attacked
but did I tell you that I used to do
that no so
one for two two new years in a row My
Buddy Joe and I we rented a zip car
Minivan and we wore if if you Google
this you'll see photos of me doing this
we wore fake afros and disco clothes
I'll try to find it but we had the it
was called the um Disco Frisco Taxi and
we would drive around uh if you look up
disco Frisco taxi you'll see my name
you'll see disco taxi and we would drive
around being like hey guys where are you
going you want to go to this place all
right cool how about uh 30 bucks and
they would say all right cool they would
get in they'd be like all right you
entered in the Disco Frisco taxi spin
the wheel you can win a juice box
brought to you by the makers of the
touchy feely wheelie which is the thing
I do Monday through Friday
yeah it's like all right your
destination is my house my home all
right yeah let's go
because it's New Year's and they're like
desperate and we would be like how about
50 bucks and they would say all right
cool uh and so we would bake like a
thousand dollars a night on New Year's I
was it was the Disco Frisco taxi so
serious I don't remember where I'll be
even going with this but uh yeah Round
Table cool into it
um really good really good I like that
where do you want to go from here we
wrapping up uh yeah let's wrap it up all
right that's the Pod we done
[Music]
foreign